We have this strange
looking shape here,
and then we're given
some of its dimensions.
We know that this side right
over here has a length of 3.5.
This side over here is 6.5.
Then we know from
here to here is 2,
and then from here to here is 7.
And then they're giving us
this dimension right over here
is 3.5.
So given that,
let's see if we can
find the area of
this entire figure.
And I encourage you to pause
the video right now and try
this on your own.
I assume you've
given a go at it.
And there might be
a few things that
jump out at you immediately.
The first thing
is that they have
these two triangles up here.
And they give us all of
the dimensions for them,
or at least they give us
the base and the height
for it, which is enough
to figure out the area.
If I had a rectangle that was 2
units wide and 3.5 units high,
if we know that it would
have an area of 2 times 3.5.
Now a triangle is
just going to be,
especially a triangle like
this, a right triangle,
is just going to be half
of a rectangle like this.
We just care about
half of its area.
So this area is going to
be 1/2 times 2 times 3.5.
1/2 times 2 is equal to 1.
1 times 3.5 is 3.5 square units.
So the area of that part is
going to be 3.5 square units.
Let's think about the area of
this triangle right over here.
Well, once again we
have its height is 3.5.
Its base is 7.
So its area is going to
be 1/2 times 7 times 3.5.
1/2 times 7 is 3.5 times 3.5.
So this part is
3.5, and I'm going
to multiply that
times 3.5 again.
Let's figure out what
that product is equal to.
3.5 times 3.5.
5 times 5 is 25.
3 times 5 is 15, plus 2 is 17.
Let's cross that out.
Move one place over to the left.
3 times 5 is 15.
3 times 3 is 9, plus 1 is 10.
So that gets us
to 5 plus 0 is 5.
7 plus 5 is 12, carry the 1.
1 plus 1 is 2.
And we have a 1.
We have two digits to the
right of the decimal, one, two.
So we're going to
have two digits
to the right of the
decimal in the answer.
The area here is
12.25 square units.
Now this region may be a
little bit more difficult,
because it's kind of us this
weird trapezoid looking thing.
But one thing that
might pop out at you
is that you can
divide it very easily
into a rectangle and a triangle.
And we can actually
figure out the dimensions
that we need to figure out
the areas of each of these.
We know what the width
of this rectangle
is, or the length of
this rectangle, whatever
you want to call it.
It's going to be 2
units plus 7 units.
So this is going to be 9.
We know that this
distance is 3.5.
If this distance right
over here is 3.5,
then this distance down here
has to add up with 3.5 to 6.5,
so this must be 3.
Now we can actually
figure out the area.
The area of this
rectangle is just
going to be its height times
its length, or 9 times 3.5.
9 times 3.5.
And one way you could
do it-- we could even
try to do this in our head--
this is going to be 9 times
3 plus 9 times 0.5.
9 times 3 is 27.
9 times 0.5, that's just half of
nine, so it's going to be 4.5.
27 plus 4 will get
us to 31, so that's
going to be equal to 31.5.
Or you could multiply it
out like this, if you like.
But the area of
this region is 31.5.
And then the area of this
triangle right over here
is going to be 9
times 3 times 1/2.
We're looking at a triangle.
9 times 3 is 27.
27 times 1/2 is 13.5.
So to find the area
of the entire thing,
we just have to
sum up these areas.
We have 31.5 plus 13.5
plus 12.25 plus 3.5.
So we just have a 5
here in the hundredths.
That's the only one.
5 plus 5 is 10, plus 7 is 17.
1 plus 1 is 2, plus 3 is 5,
plus 2 is 7, plus 3 is 10.
1 plus 3 is 4, plus
1 is 5, plus 1 is 6.
So we get a total area for this
figure of 60.75 square units.